y
aquí está lo la arriba de la torre de
sant ya que eso creo yo la amaba parís
ella pasó su adolescencia y su juventud
aquí de verdad amaba esta ciudad
lola la hija de georges salinas fue
asesinada cuando tres hombres armados
entraron en la sala de conciertos
bataclán el 13 de noviembre del 2015
tenía 28 años y le gustaba andar en
patines la música y hacer amigos
a celulares amamos aquí está lo la junto
a su mamá
90 víctimas fueron asesinadas en el
bataclán los tres atacantes también
murieron en el asalto
el padre de sam y demi moore uno de los
terroristas pidió conocer a george
sus conversaciones dieron origen a un
libro conjunto que incluye las cartas
que george escribió al atacante de 28
años
o sea me
busco a
porque esta pregunta me da vueltas desde
el 13 de noviembre porque tú y tus
cómplices cometieron estos horribles
crímenes
probaste la vida a jóvenes de tu edad a
gente que ni siquiera conocías perdiste
tú mismo la vida en hacerlo sumergida a
los padres y amigos de los que mataste y
a tus propios padres y amigos en una
pesadilla está bien es ser iglesia
consentir dejaste a los que
sobrevivieron a tus balas con heridas
permanentes marchaste tu religión a los
ojos del mundo pusiste en peligro a
todos los musulmanes algunos de los
cuales han pagado con su vida en
espantosos actos de venganza
indiscriminada todo eso con qué
propósito
este mes de septiembre se abre el
proceso de los acusados envueltos en
estos ataques george ha decidido hablar
frente a la corte
lula
lola es una de las víctimas de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre y no deseo
que esté ausente del juicio de esos
asesinos
[Música]
maestros psicólogos y trabajadores
penitenciarios a menudo piden a georges
que dé charlas sobre lola
él lleva fotos de su hija describe su
personalidad y explica lo que le pasó un
trabajo que busca prevenir la
radicalización